في اخبارنا الاخرى انتقد الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان عدم الاغتراف الدولي
بالازمه السوريه واقتصارا مساعها على وضع
المصاعب امام اللاجئين
اليونان بالتعامل مع اللاجئين بطريقه
وصفها بالوحشيه كذلك في كلمه القاها
الرئيس التركي في اسطنبول خلال مؤتمر
القضاء الدستوري لدول العالم الاسلامي
للاسف الشديد الانسانيه فشلت في امتحان
الازمه السوريه التي اودت بحياه اكثر من
مليون سوريين خلال 12 عاما ورغم ان احدا
لم يهتم بالسوريين سوى تركيا وحفنه من
الدول فان الغربه ومؤسساته اجبران لاجئين
اليهم على الخروج وتم حبسهم خلف الاسلاك
الشائكه اما تصرف اليونان الوحشي احيانا
اللاجئين فشهده كل يوم من اتلافهم لقوارب
اللاجئين بغرض اغراقهم عدا عن تعذيبهم
وتعريتهم وطردهم وللاسف فان الدول الغربيه
لا تكترث لظلال اليونان او ظلمها ولا
تحاول حمايه اللاجئين بمن فيهم النساء
والاطفال